first of all I want to start by saying
how much I enjoy your paintings
and it is ideal but at this time the
world is very important to people
throughout fly light to shine a light on
what's wrong and I really want to say
thank you for what you're doing here I
get as much out as anybody else and for
me it's it's always good
when something traumatic is happening
with something horrible is said about
you
the world is coming in front you can
turn it in are I go right to the studio
and start creating something it's my
only defense against them you know and
it might be small might be insignificant
but everybody needs to have a voice
right now
they're educating people in a very
sinister way you know and there are
generations coming up and God's entirely
with tyranny is for us to remind them
what that is and what the result is
I can turn it into something beautiful
that's wonderful to me I really might be
biting and invite others but to me the
act of you know creating a piece of art
out of whatever's happening in getting
its way I get to talk to you today what
was it about the sonic script in this
project I said I'm gonna do it but I
want to be involved you're fun you know
I just that's how I operate these days
it's if it's something I think that I
can explore a new side of myself or I
can actually go back and hit that really
absurd energy you know that people
really love those types of characters it
was an opportunity to do that again or
the Grinch or things like that it's
always fun territory to step back into
it just suspends all care evil is fun
but also intelligence is really funny if
it's accompanied with a warped ego
you know what thank you so much